إنه أروع وقت في السنة
لمواصلة البقاء نشيطًا خلال
أوقات الشتاء خاصة خلال
مواسم الأعياد ، فنحن نستهلك بالفعل
الكثير من السعرات الحرارية ، ولهذا السبب
نحتاج إلى الحفاظ على لياقتنا البدنية
بشكل أكبر للتأكد من مواجهة هذا
التأثير الرياضي  الطب يقول الدكتور تيموثي ميلر
في مركز ويكسنر الطبي بولاية أوهايو
إن التمرين على مدار العام أمر بالغ الأهمية
للصحة العقلية والبدنية ،
ويقول إنك تحصل على المزيد من
التمرين في أشهر الشتاء
لأن أجسامنا يجب أن تعمل
بجهد أكبر قليلاً مع  فيما يتعلق بعملية التمثيل الغذائي لدينا
للمساعدة في الحفاظ على درجة حرارة الجسم الأساسية ،
يمكننا في الواقع حرق المزيد من
السعرات الحرارية في التدريب على الطقس البارد
أكثر مما يمكننا فعله أثناء التدريب على الطقس الدافئ
للقيام بذلك بأمان ، يقول ميلر ارتداء الملابس
المناسبة 50 درجة فهرنهايت
وأكثر من ذلك يقول إن طبقة واحدة ربما تكون
يكفي كل 10 إلى 15 درجة تحت 50
إضافة طبقة أخرى يقول إن الطبقة الأعمق
يجب أن تبتعد الرطوبة عن
الجسم  يجب أن تكون الطبقة الثانية من
الصوف أو الصوف الصناعي الذي يحمل بعض
الحرارة ، وإذا كانت السماء تمطر أو
عاصفًا ، فيقول إن الطبقة الثالثة يجب أن تكون
قشرة من النايلون لحماية جسمك
من العناصر التي يقول أيضًا إنها تحافظ على
الطاقة وتحافظ على حرارة الجسم عن طريق القيام بذلك.
الجزء الأصعب من التمرين أولاً
إذا كنت ستجري ، دعنا نقول أن الجري للخارج
والعودة ، أشجع الناس على الجري
باتجاه الريح أولاً بهذه الطريقة يحصلون
على الجزء الأصعب منه بعيدًا
عن الطريق وحتى عندما يكون الجو باردًا
البقاء رطبًا أمرًا مهمًا بشكل عام ،
نوصي بحوالي لتر من
السوائل الزائدة لكل ساعة من
التمارين القوية للصحة ، أنا
ماندي غايثر